my name is Lisa I'm the general manager
and my girl just said you got a little
disrespectful with her Oh what you might
have thought you were just having a
little fun but I have a zero-tolerance
policy on disrespect so you're gonna
have to go blow me this is a mainstream
place so it's fruits and big screens I
will say our strategy moving you know
sort of away from boobs and into butts
you're not wearing a whole lot of
clothes but it's a family place like
working at Chili's or Applebee's except
from the tips already better if you know
how to work it
notice how I open my mouth real wide
when I laugh like when you're Main
Street Bar n grill please come here
please
come here she's making sick money though
there's a guy going up in there if they
just mess up my cable
losing your mind
you're not leaving you're married to
this place
I do love that highway Sam close my eyes
and it's like I'm at the beach
you just shake that thang someplace else
I'm just here for the burger in the
fight
you girls are not nearly hot enough to
block this kind of ball you should
apologize no drop you really want me to
tell the bunch of 20 year-old girl no
you really think that helping someone
means you get to tell them how to live
their life I started this day off crying
let's finish products when your boss
really cares about you oh the sisterhood
growing stronger
sisterhood Wow
[Applause]
you
you